yeah my name is rob pastone and i am one
of the
investor owners of keller williams vip
and i am
also a real estate agent rob how hot is
the housing market right now
right now it's blistering it's very hot
a lot of factors low inventory low
interest rates works out you know
buyers have an opportunity to lock in at
low interest rates at a historic low for
30 years
i mean it's a win-win situation for
everybody so that's why the market is so
hot right who's buying these houses
oh boy a little everything a lot of
people relocating here from california a
lot of investors getting in
um it's it's a perfect mix of a lot of
people trying to
you know they've outgrown their home
they're in covid or maybe downsizing
there's a lot of different factors right
now especially people relocating here
from out of state
so what are some of the challenges or
things that people are seeing when
purchasing a home
you know depending on the price point
but you know
the tricky thing is is when you're
trying to buy a home right now some of
the
sellers that have done really good
things to their homes really really well
presented homes
are getting top dollar for the home so
that's where the most competition is
although there is competition across the
field but you start getting into those
lower price points under 400 000 and i
can't believe i'm saying that in las
vegas but
yeah the competition is very fierce do
we need cash when purchasing a home
it helps it helps you know to to a
seller right now
money is money i mean we do everything
we can we write letters we
you know try to portray the buyer in the
best light you know because you know
some people do
want their home to go to a good family
so we try to get lucky as we can but we
we throw every tool in the
in the every trick in the toolbox in
there so tell me some tips what can we
tell our viewers
in terms if they're looking to buy a
home or if they're right now in the
process of buying a home
don't jump into it without being
educated you know find a good
professional to work with
get yourself if you're financing get
yourself pre-qualified
with someone that's got a good
reputation
it's just like anything if you're going
to go get surgery from a doctor you're
going to go get a good doctor if you're
going to go to a good cpa
you got to get a good cap it's the same
thing with your real estate agent your
loan officer
make sure they have a good reputation
ask them questions
and do some research and the last
question can we see what
uh this year can we see what happened in
the year of 2008 can we see a similarity
there will that happen again
yeah you know i hear that question a lot
and uh i don't believe that's going to
happen again that was a completely
different
uh trigger that caused that housing
collapse at that point and
you know right now as we speak right now
a lot of homeowners over the last 10
years have bought a lot of homes here in
las vegas when it was at its low so a
lot of homeowners in las vegas are in a
very strong equity position so
i don't see another foreclosure crisis
happening can foreclosures happen
sure but i don't see a crisis happening
anytime soon thank you for your time
you're welcome